حكيم على زوجها من قبل بحيازه النقد
الاجنبي واليوم هي المتهمه بتهمه الثراء
الحرام والمشبوه داخل محكمه جرائم الفساد
ومخالفات المال العام بالخرطوم وبعد ثلاث
سنوات من المداولات على وداد بابكر زوجه
الرئيس المعزول عمر البشير اضف المحكمه
بمصادره عقارات واراضي زراعيه ومشغوله
ذهبيه ورغم ضخامه الغرامه التي تقدر ب 100
مليون جنيه لصالح حكومه السودان الا ان
العقوبه مخففه بنظره قانونيين لم تتم
محاكمتها بموجب قانون ازاله تمكين او
قانون يعني التغيير الاجتماعي حصل يعني
بموجه مقتضياته وقوانينه وانما بقانون
الغاز ذات نفسه كثير من القانونيين
السودانيين يعتقدوا ان هذا الحكم جاء يعني
مخففا لم ياتي هذا الحكم مشدده
الشده المفترضه والمتوقع
على الجانب الاخر يرى المدافعون عن وداد
بابكر ان المحكمه شابتها مخالفات وانهم
ماضون في استئناف القرار الان القرار من
المحكمه اليوم صدر كل ممتلكات ابناء على
الرغم منه ابناء برده مواجهه اتهام وفصل
البلاغ في مواجهتهم او فصول الالتهاب في
مواجهه الممارسه المحليه من يقدم
مواطنون ان الاجراء هو الطريق الصحيح
لاسترداد اموال الدوله المنهوبه عبر
القضاء لارسال العداله
دائما لانه صورتنا
ثوره امنيه على ثلاثه اجزاء
حريه
سلام عداله
في اموال مهربه
السوداني يجيب لنا الحياه
تضع المواطن السوداني مراقبه لهذا الملف
الشائك بين رغبه في تحقيق العداله وخوف من
ضياع حقه لن يعقوب العربيه الخرطوم